bonjour bienvenue en direct de la clusaz
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler du
test de turing idéologique qu'une notion
introduite par l'économiste brahim
caplanne et l'idée c'est un peu de
tester votre hooliganisme en testant
votre capacité à défendre correctement
le camp qui vous est opposé vincent
c'est vraiment un test ultime de
l'empathie cognitifs dont on a parlé
dans un épisode précédent c'est-à-dire
la capacité à comprendre ce qui se passe
dans le cerveau d'une autre personne et
quels sont les arguments qu'elle a en
tête
typiquement une bonne façon d'y arriver
c'est être capable d'expliquer à cette
personne ce qu'elle pense comment elle
pense et si possible y arriver encore
mieux qu'elle n'y parviendrait elle même
on peut penser que dans une situation de
débat un petit peu frontale ça soit une
stratégie pour montrer à l'autre qu'il a
tort mais pas du tout l'idée d'un test
de turing idéologique est quelque chose
d extrêmement instructif
y compris lorsque vous cherchez à aller
dans le sens de l'autre à comprendre ce
qu'il pense et à consolider ce qu'il
pense il est très utile de comprendre à
ce moment là la manière dont il
réfléchit et pourquoi est ce qu'ils
pensent ce qu'ils pensent typiquement
même lorsqu'un ami vous raconte quelque
chose avec lequel vous êtes
a priori d'accord il est alors utile de
chercher à reformuler ce qu'il dit pour
vérifier que vous avez bel et bien
compris ce qu'il a dit mais aussi pour
aider l'autre personne a trouvé de
meilleure façon de formuler ses propres
idées mais bien sûr le test de turing
les cas beaucoup plus dure encore
lorsque l'autre à des avis contraires ou
une autre et pour vous entraîner à faire
ce test de turing logique vous propose
le paradoxe la situation un peu
bizarroïdes suivante
imaginez que vous vous rêviez tout à
coup dans une chambre complètement fermé
il n'y a pas de fenêtre et aucun accès
sur monde extérieur à part une
un écran sur lequel il ya ça a l'air
d'être un tri corps en direct et le truc
en direct que vous voyez là c'est 100
personnes qui sont en train d'être
attaché de partout et à côté de cet
écran il y a un bouton avec une tête de
mort est également un texte qui dit que
si jamais vous appuyez sur ce bouton
alors les 100 personnes que vous voyez à
l'écran vont être électrocutée sous vos
yeux et qui plus est la décharge ils
vont recevoir et immortel donc nous
sommes en fait ils vont avoir
d'horribles souffrances mais en plus ils
vont finir par mourir tout ce que vous
avez à faire c'est pour réfléchir
pendant une heure à est ce que vous
allez à pied sur ce bouton gré une offre
faite pour appuyer sur ce bouton
la question c'est est-ce que vous
appuyez sur ce bouton priori normalement
la réponse est non sauf que dans ce
texte il est également écrit que vous
faites partie d'une expérience et en
fait c'est super convaincant pour une
raison x ou y vous y croyez vraiment et
dans cette expérience en fait il ya une
super intelligent ce qui a fait une
prédiction sur ce que vous allez faire
on va supposer que la prédiction de la
super intelligent c'est juste à 99 99%
en gros vous pouvez vraiment vraiment
lui faire confiance et ce qui se passe
d'un peu bizarre c'est que en fonction
de la prédiction de la super intelligent
sur ce que vous allez faire la super
intelligent se faire quelque chose s'il
avait super intelligence prédit que vous
n'allez pas appuyé sur le bouton alors à
10 heures pile poil à lens dvd drones
qui vont tuer un million de personnes
puis les trous noirs en revenir au
bercail
si bien que voilà onze auront tout est
réglé si jamais à 9 heures l'un des
super intelligent ça prédit que vous
n'appuyez pas sur le bouton alors à 10h
en gros en fin de quart d'heure 1
million de personnes ont été tuées
al'inverse si un super intelligence
prédit que vous appuyez sur le bouton
bouton pour torturer et tuer les 100
personnes que vous voyez à l'écran alors
à ce moment-là super intelligence ne
tuera personne et du coup à 11 heures il
se passera rien il se passera l'once a
jamais de drogue pour ceux qui que ce
soit quoi qu'il en soit en tout cas à 11
heures voilà super intelligent ce
s'autodétruire on n'entend plus jamais
parler basse et c'est un truc qui est
fini il est midi face et non dans le
passé il est midi vous êtes dans la
salle et vous devinez que vous croyez à
100% pour des raisons x ou y et tout ce
que je viens de dire est ce que vous
appuyez sur le bouton
alors j'ai jamais posé cette énigme est
a priori vous devez avoir une intuition
d'une réponse qui est soit oui où sont
annoncés aux appuis et si vous appuyez
pas et si possible faudrait que ça a été
une option c'est assez forte
maintenant si c'est le cas
ce que vous demande de le faire lui même
si pas le cas vous en train de le faire
vous allez lancer une pièce qu'ils
fassent lancé bien vous trichez pas et
si la pièce tombe sur piles écrivait en
commentaire quelque chose qui défend
votre position un argument expliquer
pourquoi est ce que vous pensez ce que
vous pensez et est créée par pat est
énorme mais écrivait un peu plus que de
ligne c'est quand même de développer un
argument si la pièce que vous avez dansé
les tombes surface cette fois fait l'
inverse c'est-à-dire défendez la
position contraire à la vôtre et essayer
d'être un exemple très convaincant fait
face dans le test de turing logique et
c'est de donner les arguments que vous
pensez que d'autres donnerait pour
défendre la position opposée
voilà donc ça c'est le test de turing
idéologie curieux de voir vos réponses
et de voir si vous arrivez à vous faire
passer pour l'autre et puis par ailleurs
vous pouvez lire les commentaires des
autres et essayer de deviner si leur
pièce est tombée sur ping sur ce site
mais sur pas c'est à dire est ce que ils
défendent la position en laquelle il
croit pour éviter que vous soyez cité
hors contexte vous invite à écrire le
hashtag test de turing idéologique avant
d'écrire d'autres réponses comme ça ça
signalera que peut-être une chance sur
deux que vous défendez en fait votre
vraie proposition et d'ailleurs vous
invite à faire ça également sur twitter
ou ailleurs essayer de vous tester de
tester votre capacité à vous faire
passer pour quelqu'un d'autre tout cas
d'un point de vue idéologique jamais le
paradoxe que j'ai donnés ci qui est
inspirée en fait du paradoxe newcombe
dont on a pas mal parlé avec thibault
dans plusieurs épisodes d'axoum si
jamais ça ça ne vous inspire pas bien je
vous invite à faire le test de turing
idéologique pour le paradoxe est
originale de nu comme en tout cas celui
qu'on a expliqué dans un épisode axium
ou alors vous pouvez prendre d'autres
sujets par exemple sujet réalisé me
versus sentir à l'isthme tiré une pièce
et si ces piles vous défendez la
position à laquelle vous croyez si c'est
face ou défendez la position qu'elle ne
croyait pas il faut que votre
argumentaire soit toujours convaincant
que vous ayez soin est tombé sur piles
ou surface et si jamais tous ces sujets
ne vous inspirent toujours pas vous
invite à part et par un peu de la
singularité toujours avec le hashtag
test de turing idéologique ou encore
vous pouvez prendre d'autres sujets
comme juste par l'automatisation leur
revenu universel fâche pas avec ses
chars ya plein d'idées que pouvait avoir
en tête prenez votre sujet préféré
surtout si vous avez un avis marqué et
fait ce que j'ai dit a tiré une pièce
essayé de passer le test de turing
je pense que c'est un effort qui est
moins instructif pour la personne qui
fait cet effort et qui également qu'il
va faire également réfléchir et bien
qu'ils lisent ce genre de commentaire je
pense que c'est quand même bon réflexe à
avoir que d'essayer de passer de temps
en temps un test de turing idéologique
en tout cas je vous invite à essayer de
faire dans les commentaires de cette
vidéo san sol ou sur twitter ou même
dans la vie avec vos amis ou autre et
dernière chose si vous faites ça surtout
si vous devez défendre le côté opposé
soyez bienveillant vraiment donner la
version la meilleure version du côté
opposé
je galèje parle de l'homme de faire
opposition aux hommes de paille du côté
opposé vraiment donner vraiment la plus
belle version possible du camp opposé
surtout ne soyez pas sarcastique s'il
vous plaît